so what do you think it's gonna take to
kind of change this this cultural thing
that we have going on though I mean
obviously it's a huge economic lift
companies well we'll see what happens
after this virus I think we're gonna
live in a different world like right now
there's not one dolphinarium open
anywhere in the world right now there is
not one dolphin or a moment and how long
can they hope we're good you know you're
gonna see half the restaurants in your
town are gonna be gone places you grew
up eating at are gonna be gone forever
your movie theater is probably after
this there probably won't be an AMC
movie theater anymore like things are
going to be gone it's gonna change
things a lot and I you know after the
dolphinariums won't make it through this
easily half of them omega-c world stock
right now is in the gutter like how many
months of this can they how many months
can they not be open was that something
that you guys have talked about have you
guys have you guys to have discussed but
I've just doubled the size of my
facility in the past 30 days I'm ready
all right my staff is red or any place
that closes we're ready to take all
their dough I can take every dolphin
right now in Indonesia we're ready to go
so you guys are kind of anticipating
that this is gonna happen to me
absolutely okay well we build in Bali
that can be replicated in Mexico it can
be we're gonna see place is closing left
and right Wow man that is sent them to
keep captive dolphins if they eat a lot
of fish every day and you got to have a
big staff we have a full-time
veterinarian like most facilities don't
have a full-time bet they have a guy
that comes once every few months like
it's not cheap to have all that like how
long can they hang on yeah no it's it's
very interesting how there's kind of
like this weird silver lining in this
whole virus thing how it's changing it's
turning around the environment with
pollution as far as pollution goes water
pollution air pollution and then now
this with with animal captivity
obviously people can't be going to zoos
or aquariums change our entire
relationship that would be a benefit the
whole thing was started by eating
animals and like you know every animal
place right now there's no way they're
not open and how long can they do that
for and do you know and then when it's
not like
the country's not gonna open up like
Thursday and it's back open like it's
gonna we're all getting use to this like
you think you're gonna shake someone's
hand ever again ever again
right you think that's gonna change like
there's things that are just done like
when and if the economy
I mean I'm gonna say when the economy
does start to come back I don't think I
mean it's safe to say that zoos and
aquariums are not going to be the first
place people go to no nightclubs movie
theaters no these are the last places
anyone's going to right exactly and so
what are they gonna do like you know I
totally anticipate like them removing
every other seat on an airplane and
doubling the price of tickets like I'm
just meeting that's what the air travel
will get more exclusive but like can
they afford only let half the amount of
people into SeaWorld and charge twice as
much probably no one's gonna pay $200 we
got a SeaWorld like no I just don't see
that model working and like you know
there's stupid they had their chance
like when black fish came out around
that same time there was also a big push
against Ringling Brothers Circus and the
elephants and so they finally threw in
the towel and said we're getting rid of
the elephants and then a year later
after a hundred eighty years in business
they were out of business like it's just
the inci world didn't see the writing on
the wall they double down on animals in
captivity where they should have been
backing off because you go to SeaWorld
half of it is roller coasters and roller
coasters we were VR goggles like they
have such an opportunity to do such an
amazing thing they could have a theater
that holds 200 people with one guy
hitting a green button and a red button
to start in the show and that's the only
cost after they spend a million bucks
making the BR film and they'll have the
most unbelievable experience in the
world mm-hmm
instead they've gotta have dolphins and
they guys often say gosh they got
problems they got people protesting
they've got controversy they've got
overhead what do these people say that
run these places what do they say it
what is their response to you like what
would they say to me right now it's like
that is corporate like of course like
you know there's people that are working
day to day or the animals are
well-meaning people like they you know
they think well if I quit my job as a
trainer who's
take his good care of the dolphin they
all want the best care it's the
corporate heads you know of course you
look on the bottom of SeaWorld's website
it's called the SeaWorld Entertainment
Corporation they're not an educational
they're an entertainment corporation
point-blank and so it's just so what
what would those corporate figures at
the top of SeaWorld that basically they
see you as one of their biggest enemies
they see you as the people that are
trying to take them down have you
listened to any of them have you had
like a discussion with any of those
people have you listened to them respond
to movies like The Cove or respond to
movies like blackfish do you know what
they're like denied in fact there's a
massive lawsuit they've lost all their
initial hearings where you know the
first year after blackfurs came out and
their stock when the toilet
they said they were it was it was
affected by weather on certain dates or
that holidays thought they said ever
excuse but blackfish and now all those
investors are suing like that could be
the end of SeaWorld if they win this
lawsuit because all the investors are
suing that what you screwed us you live
point-blank that it was having no effect
when you were internally freaking out
like you know I I don't get it it's just
you know it's like without the orcas
they lose the orcas or the DRA we have a
place here in Miami Seaquarium know in
Miami they have Lolita the day Lolita
dies is gone
like they're close to that they're done
two months later that is what keeps a
play is going and so it's just a matter
of time yeah it's just money mm-hmm
that's all that you're saying like why
it's just why they have a keep going
it's money but I think they would make
just as much money as a theme park that
was aquatic themed and had Burke use
port reality and 3d and all the
different things we have available
augmented reality you could do something
amazing amazing yeah absolutely well I
really appreciate your time doing this
man I've learned a lot yeah yeah tell me
it tell me all your social media links
and what your websites are so people can
listen to go find them and I'll also
later
and Instagram and Twitter and twitch
were at Dolphin underscore project you
all of our accounts on all our alla
social media platforms are all verified
so you'll know that it's us and you guys
update the website almost monthly or
weekly on the projects you guys are
working on where you guys are traveling
we're writing we have a full-time staff
that's writing new blogs and I think
social media post goes out every four
hours 24 hours a day we're very active
social media and we're live-streaming
all the time and you know people there's
a tons of stuff people can do on the
website it just depends on their time
and involvement but the most simplistic
thing people can do
it's just don't buy a ticket to a
dolphin show and as simplistic and easy
as that sounds it's all driven by supply
and demand and if you don't buy any more
tickets to dolphin shows you don't go on
cruises that have dolphins you don't
stay in a hotel that's got dolphins
they'll want a business and they'll get
the nest that's the only thing their way
they get the message mm-hmm corporate
anyone yeah I think it's definitely
starting to I think the scale is
starting to tip now and people are
definitely starting to realize that more
and more as you know people like
yourself and your father and and there's
lots of other people that are very vocal
about it and talk about it on shows like
this literally 20 years ago it would be
us by ourselves in front of aquarium now
we host an event called empty the tanks
where simultaneous like simultaneously
we protest like a hundred and seventy
different facilities around the world at
the same day at the same time like you
know now it's become this giant
groundswell movement and so we just hope
to god guide that movement now it's
kind of changed our work a little bit